[Music]
Cape Town is running out of water after
three years of unprecedented drought it
could be the first major city in the
world to go dry and nearly a dozen more
around the world are facing the same
risk this is supposed to be Cape Town's
a main dam but it's looking more like a
desert did the city of Cape Town fail to
act early enough it's always easy in
retrospect to say well we could have
started you idiot
if de0 arrives the south african city of
4 million will shut off the taps for all
but essential facilities like hospitals
in a region defined by deep racial and
economic disparity the threat of dry
taps is highlighting the stark divide
between the haves and the have-nots I'd
be always good water but yeah we're as
suffering from water but in the end
everyone in Cape Town could be left
without water we're in Newlands which is
an affluent suburb at the slope of Table
Mountain its natural spring has always
provided water for local residents but
now thousands come from miles away as
early as 5:00 a.m. to fill up their jugs
this is now a common sight in Cape Town
long lines at one of the city's natural
springs where people are collecting
fresh water in an attempt to conserve
the ever scarce municipal water coming
from the tap it's a time-consuming but
cost-effective alternative to buying
water sometime there's no money food so
we must coming up how worried are you
about day zero when the tops might run
dry that's for me for why because this
is my photo sticky fountains HIV
positive and I can't even get water
what is medicine so I must comply with
the government must some enterprising
caped onehans are turning crisis into
opportunity with online offers to
deliver water for those willing to pay
others are selling rainwater collection
tanks and installing water collection
systems in homes it's smart business
since water especially bottled has been
in high demand when de xira appeared
imminent bottles would sell out in
stores now
many Cape Tony uns have settled into the
realization that conservation is their
way of life the situation is really bad
but we coping getting used to this
connecting over to a very thirdly this
is the new normal that we just do it
seems like this are not what most
Outsiders think of when they hear Cape
Town the coastal city is better known as
a tourist destination with multi-million
dollar beachfront properties but three
years of unprecedented drought and rapid
population growth coupled with
inadequate planning have plunged this
paradise into panic this is Cape Town's
main reservoir supplying more than half
of the city's water
I should be underwater right now but as
you can see there is none in sight the
reservoir is down to just 10% of its
capacity the last nine percent of the
water is unusable because of the high
mix of sand in it making it almost mud
the winter rainfall runs from May to
August but rain alone is unlikely to
save Cape Town instead city officials
are instructing residents to limit their
daily water use per person 250 liters or
13 gallons a day
there are signs all around town
reminding people to conserve and some
public spaces have already shut off
their taps so as you can see in this
public restroom there's signs saying
that washing hands is prohibited in fact
the fixtures on all the sinks are
removed and over here there's a sign
that says that due to the current water
crisis showers and some tops have been
disconnected in February
farmers opened their dams to allow about
2.6 million gallons of water to flow to
the drought stricken city such combined
efforts have helped to push back day
zero but the Doomsday remains a moving
target in a city where a water crisis
only highlights the deep disparity
between residents what's now considered
the new normal for all Cape Toni ins is
everyday life for black residents living
in townships under the apartheid system
blacks were forced to live in barren
under-resourced communities called
townships like this one where they
continued to live today Shepherd is
among the 25% of Cape Tony uns who live
in townships all of which combined use
less than 5% of the city's water they
don't have taps in their homes or
toilets or showers
so every time you need to get water this
is what you do this is what they do with
what about when you want to wash
yourself to power no there's no silences
you must it water and go to you and go
to their home put some water on the
kettle light the kettle and you just
throw it in the bathroom and you're wash
yourself how many times a day do you do
this or how many times a week a week I
can say maybe 20 times 20 times a week
yes I asked Shepard to show me how he
feels what he calls his bath maybe do
you feel half the Sun yes do you feel
like now that everybody in Capetown is
suffering from a water shortage that the
richer people and the white people are
getting a glimpse into your experience
it's not the same not the same you white
people always go to water but yeah but
as suffering from water Townships
already experienced regular water
shutoffs and city officials say they'll
be exempt from a citywide shutdown on
day zero the city's conservation
campaigns are instead targeted at
suburbs which are among the most water
wasteful they're also where most white
residents live
Anita Shapiro is doing her best to meet
the city's water guidelines her family
doesn't water their lawn or fill their
pool and have learned to collect
rainwater did you know any of this
before no you basically had to learn the
piping the water infrastructure of this
whole house Anita's home has more
conservation signage than most public
facilities she also uses wet wipes
instead of washing her hands if it's
yellow let it Mellow take short showers
and collects the grey water to flush the
toilet with her neighbors have also
drilled a borehole and let her draw
groundwater from it how do you feel
about the fact that Cape Town has gotten
to this
of severe water shortage it's quite
shocking I think to to first contemplate
the thought of there being no water in
taps I mean it with this magic if you
open a tap and his water new suddenly
you have to realize it's not magic
there's politics behind it there's they
dance behind it there is engineering
behind it and people have failed us the
local government is failures failed us
the national government has failed us
officials are now scrambling to
construct three expensive but temporary
small-scale desalination plants that
would purify seawater into drinkable
water delivered through taps a two-year
plant seems kind of just like a band-aid
and not a long-term solution we don't
know where this or no rain we don't know
what the condition is going to be so buy
ourselves time to check get additional
water into the system the second thing
is it also provides us enough time it
make sure that we get the long-term
visualization and the permanent
assimilation blonde up remaining so this
is like buying time in a very expensive
way I won't say it's just buying thought
I think we need to provide water we need
to get self-sufficient we need weed we
want to get the sustainability back and
we need to make sure that the kept
honest care has got enough water to
drink but knowledge of the impending
crisis goes back decades so why is the
city only now taking serious action I
asked the deputy mayor who was recently
put in charge of dealing with the water
crisis I went to the theaters cliff dam
yesterday I saw how shockingly empty it
is but that didn't happen overnight
so did the city of Cape Town fail to act
early enough it's always easy in
retrospect when you know that you had
that situation to say well we could have
started earlier and obviously if we had
started earlier we would have been in a
more comfortable position but we would
still have to be in a position where we
had very significant water restrictions
in order to to get through this period
of crisis during my time here the
drought was declared a national
emergency there are skeptics who say
that the Democratic Alliance which runs
the city of Cape Town
waited for things to get this bad in
order for the national government run by
the ANC to come and shoulder the burden
what do you say to that
well I mean that's pathetic to be honest
you know this crisis came upon us
through the lack of rainfall and
everyone has acknowledged for the last
three years that that there is an
inadequate rainfall the national
government in terms of the South African
Constitution is responsible for bulk
water supply so it has been their
responsibility to step up to the plate
in the meantime the city is taking
additional steps including lowering the
pressure in its water system installing
larger desalination plants tapping into
aquifers and mountains for groundwater
and turning wastewater to drinking water
so we went from 3 million people to 4
million people overnight and so the
ability of the city to to service people
is stretched because you have this
massive growth in population but there's
a lag in the economic growth what's
happening here in Cape Town can't be
dismissed as unique only 3% of the water
covering the Earth's surface is
freshwater and already more than a
billion people around the world live in
water scarce regions the UN has
projected that the global demand for
freshwater will exceed the supply by 40
percent in 2030 and that's due to
population growth climate change and
human action meanwhile in Cape Town as
the city struggles to push back day zero
its citizens are forced to change their
relationship to water and how they use
it possibly forever hey guys it's Dina
here at cape town's main reservoir
that's what's going on with the water
crisis here watch our next video where
you see what it means to live on 50
liters of water a day be sure to LIKE
comment and share this video subscribe
to aj+ and check out more of my
reporting direct from